that stupid respectfully you sound
bitter now and and and you sound like a
a battered woman making excuses this
other fight that's brewing with the
Republicans right now that I think
clearly for the next year is going to
overshadow everything uh which is the
Trump to Santa situation because uh Anne
couter who was one of the main Trump
backers like one of the first people
back in 2015 to back Trump uh she's no
longer into Donald uh she's she's moved
to Camp to santis she was on Patrick Bet
David's podcast yesterday and they got
into it it got it got pretty uh pretty
Tiffy you could say uh over some of
Trump's perceived failures at least from
man's perspective he is that stupid
respectfully you sound bitter now and
and and the reason why he don't lie to
us when you're campaigning and getting
our votes B you sound like a a battered
woman making excuses well maybe he won't
hit me next time it's been four years
he's been beating the crap out of you he
had four years Patrick four years two
with a Republican
oh but I know he he could have not hit
me but maybe he was thinking he was
waiting for our golden anniversary to
stop hitting me he was just waiting for
that perfect time no he had four years
he didn't build it I don't know what
other proof you could possibly besides
Co that was very big in 2020 and you say
and this reminds me that you want you
want to feel safe and boy we don't feel
safe now especially New York and La God
Philly all these places San Francisco I
mean if you're a city person like I am
where where do you go anyway um and that
was the George Floyd May 25th 2020
change the world we suddenly we have to
release all the criminals among other
things um one place you would have been
safe in 2020 was in Florida thank you
Ronda Santos passing law after law where
you can shoot looters anti- rting laws I
mean there were specific actions he took
that made that meant there were no riots
and no police stations were burnt down
and you did not have police being
assaulted what did the commander and
chief do what did Trump do he sent out
Tweets in all caps Law and Order point
one point two at the first debate what
did Donald Trump say to Joe Biden you
called them super Predators I'm
releasing people from prison how about
the first step act thank you Jared he's
releasing criminals you want to feel
safe Donald Trump ain't your
guy I mean man she went on and on and on
and I don't think she said anything that
was untrue there don't you have to keep
in mind she also wrote a book called in
Trump We Trust she was also on Bill
Maher in 2015 saying Trump was going to
be the nominee when he was polling at
like 20 25% something like that uh Sarah
like I don't even know what to say wow
cter yeah yeah that's quite the uh quite
the turnaround look I know for Anne
couter her number one issue was the
border and you know she is very upset
that the border is not secure I will say
look Trump saying we're going to make
Mexico pay for it I always found to be
Preposterous because anyone who
understands how things work knows you
can't force another country to pay for
your La he's admitted it's a lie since
then in essence he didn't say lie yeah
and and I thought that that was that was
a stumble I thought for him to say oh
come on you couldn't have possibly
believed that because I mean you want to
believe that when a politician is
telling you that they're going to do
something that they actually intend to
do it um so I did think that that was a
stumble for his campaign and I I don't
blame her for being upset I will say he
did have a Congress that fought him a
lot of the time on funding the border
wall uh every step of the way but still
she has very reasonable critiques of
Donald Trump that I think he needs to
answer for I think that when you add in
all of the co stuff too Donald Trump was
very good and very effective at a lot of
things Donald Trump also had a lot of
weaknesses specifically during coid that
I think that he needs to answer for and
I think that the problem is that not
only has he not answered for them he's
actually doubled down on a lot of them
uh he's doubled down on the vaccine
still when it's just this bizarre uh
place where you know you have the
majority of conservatives now who are
totally against this vaccine but still
are okay with trump touting
it